hey I'm ability hi I'm Lisa and I'm Josh
wolf I'm Jon Taffer hi I'm Jim Norton of
Logan Paul I'm here with my boy Cody
I don't know well Ryan killing them I'm
Brendan Schaub how many coming so it's
David Spade I'm here to answer the
Internet in one take that was good would
you rather be a bad kisser or give bad
head [ __ ] this is so like hard because
I'm really good at both I start guys are
always like you give like the best
[ __ ] ever so but [ __ ] I like no I
have to give up good kissing because a
giving head is like an art form like
it's so much fun I love it like that's
why I'm like completely bisexual because
I like both so much if you could pick
one person from TV movies to be your
college roommate who would it be
JLo yeah we'd be roomies we could brush
each other's hair JLo
deservedly so not because of a rod
because of her would you [ __ ] the
ugliest teacher you ever had yes
oh is that not the question Oh would you
[ __ ] the obvious teacher ever had to
[ __ ] the hottest teacher you ever had
yeah listen most guys would [ __ ] the
other teacher they ever had just for the
story then that's a hard no that's a
that's a hard path there was a dude
there was a teacher that I had whose
body odor was so bad but he also used to
stand and he a Chester he had his shirt
button to hear and he would talk to you
and he would twirl the chest hair and
slowly rip it out of his chest and
sprinkle it on the ground in front of
him and his bow he smelled that dude
smelled so bad and he always had food
and his beard there was one time he had
a piece of cheese in his [ __ ] eyebrow
and I was just staring at him like
am i doing here yeah so I would say no
if you could fight one person to death
and switch lives of them if you win who
would you fight and I have to fight a
girl because I want to win you know
mm-hmm maybe Tina Fey she's fun she's
smart smart writer and I just saw her
yesterday so just came to mind all right
Tina look out a pigs orgasm lasts for
over thirty minutes I want to be a
freaking pig a lion can have sex for
over over fifty times a day which would
you rather be I'll take the fifty times
certainly of course man even if it's a
minute every time it's fifty minutes
it's better than thirty minutes
so no brainer got to work a little
harder for it though
uh would you hook up with someone with a
colostomy bag again I have already yes I
really have a hundred percent I didn't
know she had one
she didn't tell me and she told me right
before we fooled around and all
completely true we didn't have sex but
guess who went down and ate [ __ ] well
right on her I was fine with I didn't
care she was a nice girl she's pretty
she might have loved me yeah but I would
not we never spoke again I dumped her
for a girl with a catheter would you
date a girl knowing all of her previous
exes are dead [ __ ] yeah this [ __ ] is
presidential what why are they dead
those are [ __ ] that good you just die
instantly oh yeah this one weirds me out
man did she kill Homer did she just like
date super old dudes yeah it's like the
movie teeth you got nothing to worry
about though for her like gone back to
her accent or everything I would do it
she's the Kurt Cobain of vagina all
right
you had the flexibility to blow yourself
would you first of all I I do have
flexibility I'll drop in the splits
right now naked you should see my
three-piece set looks like a dead baby
bird what everybody what if everybody
knew you did I'd be like this cuz I can
[ __ ] aren't you a Christian you are
in an open field armed with a baseball
bat how many 10 year-olds this is dark
how many 10 year-olds wearing like
helmets can you take down before they
get you ah man I mean how am i running
at me I would say a few hundred a few
hundred getting can cost like a
[ __ ] you know I'm saying
Barry Bonds in these little ten years
old I'd be alright the first kid is just
he douche and they're like [ __ ] man
yeah and the rest of my I guess this
looks like a serial killer wrote it and
who did this
is this you wow this is alarming
would you rather be drunk 24/7 or never
get drunk ever again
what about weed no it's like so so I'm
either only wasted or sober forever
talk I would rap hmm I guess never get
drunk ever again but I would order
painkillers on the Internet
from Canada Oh what's the grossest thing
you've ever snapchatted this is bad
I sent my mom a new dog no go hold up
it's it's there's an asterisk I put a
emoji over my penis yes